obviously uh kanye and drake are
continuing their fake or real beef we're
not exactly sure which one it is but uh
kanye dropped a pin of basically drake's
house in toronto yeah which is
interesting which makes me feel like
this whole thing is fabricated yeah
that's too far
what do you mean too far in like even
kanye knows that's too far
uh like you're putting people's lives at
risk like and also he's dealt with this
[ __ ] so like he knows firsthand like
it's mad crazy to do that yeah so you
don't think it's his real house i don't
even like paparazzi showing up to his
house imagine like crazy fans
yeah yeah i just i just feel like this
whole thing is fast i kind of feel
people probably know where drake's crazy
three-year documentary about this
hundred million dollar house that he's
putting on in toronto on the street
called bridal path which is like it's
you saying i moved to rodeo drive like
i'm here yeah yeah
everybody knows where he lives everybody
okay so let me take that back
the only caveat that i was gonna that
was gonna put in that is um
i wouldn't make a deal with kanye if i
truly believe that he's suffering from
mental illness
i would make a deal with drake yeah okay
i go drake this is the deal we can like
let's say and i wonder if fighters ever
do this like i would do this with a
fighter i if i'm let's say i'm fighting
khabib i go yo just tell me this [ __ ] to
stay away from i'm gonna hype this fight
we're gonna make millions of dollars i'm
gonna go crazy and talk [ __ ] tell me the
things that are across the line and say
them right now but then they gotta trust
you
and and listen and if they don't that's
fine but if they want to come with me
and and i just like listen i wanna [ __ ]
you up like please i wanna make sure
you're concussed you're knocked out i
you wake up that's cool whatever but
give me the [ __ ] that is too much and if
he's smart and he wants to make [ __ ]
tens of millions of dollars with me
talking my [ __ ]
then we go and it's funny it's funny you
say that that's what happened with
dipset and the locks no yeah but they
spoke about it openly they said they hey
what's crossing the line we're going to
be a little jippy like jabs yeah jabs
and stuff like that and yo just don't
tell me to suck your dick and we'll be
good yeah and don't and don't hit me in
the face that was it that was the rule
yeah they're homies they're like look
they're homies we want to [ __ ] go at
it what can't i do yeah it was chippy i
love this i love this so there was just
like no suck dicks yeah no
no violence don't touch my face nothing
i mean it got close when cam kick uh
uh
styles yeah when cam king styles but it
was it was like yeah but you got to be
homeless though because otherwise it's
like oh i'm just going to tell you all
the worst [ __ ] about me and then you're
going to have all the ammunition to use
against me if you want to but they
respect each other that's what i'm
saying so it has to be
all right tell me your darkest secrets
not to say
yeah yeah
really
but at the same time if they don't say
anything like let's say i reached out
and then i didn't hear back from the
fighter that i was gonna fight right
i could go i could say whatever the [ __ ]
i want at that point cause i'm like yo i
asked you i was respectful i came to you
in the dms you've seen it and i said
what are the topics that you want to
avoid you looked at it and you didn't
say a single thing so now everybody's
getting to smoke your mom your family
your religion everything's good we hype
in this fight yeah i mean people still
come at you for being tasteless or
whatever anybody any of his fans are
going to come at me no matter what right
but if they're more angry they're buying
that pay-per-view yeah they're not going
to watch the reruns true so
i would do that with someone like drake
because i feel like this guy is just
strictly business this [ __ ]
knows what's going on kanye i don't
believe it kanye type person like he
could have a deal with you and then that
[ __ ] has thrown out the window mm-hmm
kanye billionaire too so it's like he
you don't really need the money the
promo connie building [ __ ] houses in
soldier field like
this is literally all ego yeah the whole
thing is ego
you haven't heard of the rap game before
it's so funny uh duval's the greatest
bro i love how he just trashes rappers
yeah all his friends are rappers but
he's like he was posing pictures of this
private jet he's like if rappers really
had the money that they talking about
they'd be flying and they'd be flying
and jets would look like this not the
little [ __ ] so he goes at least i own my
little [ __ ]
it was like the best way to say i own a
plane yeah yeah
you know yeah but uh but yeah i don't
know like i think
now maybe the beef is real and literally
kanye's putting an album out just to
[ __ ] on drake
is it possible the whole album
is to [ __ ] on drake i mean yeah it's not
crazy i mean two [ __ ] flew to
space just to [ __ ] on each other you
know what i mean yeah
i mean like the wars have been fought
over [ __ ] egos getting hurt yeah to
make an album to hurt someone's ego yeah
it's not crazy but imagine that shutting
down your whole life like that's real
estate in your head because i don't
think drake is trying to [ __ ] on on yay
i think drake's going out there like
listen i'm the best of my generation and
i mean
no he's going to take shots at center
but i don't think the sole purpose of
putting out the album no no no i think
it's like i got to satisfy this deal
that i got yeah or maybe this is the
first one outside the deal or something
like that for the rapper i make rap
music lately let's go it's time right i
put the [ __ ] heart in my head it's
time for me to drop out i need to give
purpose to this [ __ ] you saw his heart
look on life support [ __ ]
he said he got covered and his hairline
got [ __ ] up
come on man don't blame it on the bed
you get a barber to come to your place
right
but uh
but yeah i don't know i just feel like
he has real estate and he is living rent
free
in kanye's head to the point where kanye
is willing to put out a whole album just
to [ __ ] on drake's really
yeah
drake did to kanye what pusha t did to
him you know drake would just keep
bringing up the pusha t [ __ ] for like a
year later he'd be in an interview
talking about it and be like dog here's
it tight move on yeah it's okay you're
still the greatest of your generation go
but he just kept [ __ ] talking kanye's
like that he's just obsessed on this
[ __ ] obsessed with drake why do you
guys think
i guess drake's like the artist of the
decade yeah and kanye sees himself kanye
was supposed to be drake's the artist is
a decade he [ __ ] everybody like you
know i mean frank is the guy yeah drake
fulfilled the potential that kanye had
you know what i mean like kanye was the
greatest like for years like those first
three albums like were unprecedented and
he was the best producer the best rapper
had like the best features like
everything
and then he went crazy i mean for that
decade or like that generation like 2006
to just yeah
anybody ever put him as the best rapper
but yeah definitely maybe the best but
kids [ __ ] worshipped him dude but now
drake's the best artist so no one's
saying drake's the best rapper he's
seeing it slip away so he and and he's
just acting uh
a little bit irrationally kind of like
connor
because he's noticing his stranglehold
on the game slip away yeah maybe he's
always been like
before recently always really
competitive remember the [ __ ] uh
lollipop remix of wayne where he was
like you knocking the bottom me like
everybody else i'd do it for the belt
like he always wanted that [ __ ] spot
um all right guys we'll take a break for
a second because i got to tell you about
the best underwear that i've ever worn
my entire life i'm not [ __ ] you it
is the best underwear i've ever worn my
entire life i'm wearing it right now
it's culprit underwear uh you guys
probably saw the ad that we did when we
were down in miami she was absolutely
crazy there's some wild [ __ ]
boys okay i love these [ __ ] boys
they're some wild [ __ ] boys but
they make the best underwear on the
planet and it is culprit underwear and
you guys are gonna wear you think i'm
bullshitting you this is what i would
say buy one pair
if they're not the best underwear you've
ever worn your entire life
i'm not gonna do anything but you'll
know that i'm right i promise you this
by at least one pair you'll know that
i'm right you'll never wear them again
my girls stealing my [ __ ] underwear i
have [ __ ] stains all over my underwear
why is my girl with them putting them on
because they're that comfortable they're
comfortable enough to wear with [ __ ]
stains on if you're a girl that's how
incredible they are yeah what
like you have [ __ ] stains on your
underwear never [ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up
okay um guys so you're gonna go do this
it's the best fabrics and all that other
[ __ ] stuff it's 95 micro modal
whatever that means i don't know what
any of these things mean okay all i know
is it's the best underwear i've ever
worn my life i haven't stopped wearing
them since i wore them everyone in this
room is wearing them right now it is not
a game
it is not a game this is not a game this
is it this is the last pair of underwear
you will ever wear simple as that you
will put them on you will keep ordering
them and that is it culprit underwear
okay culprit underwear dot com use the
code flagrant you're gonna get 20 off 20
off of the best underwear in the
business use that code flagrant don't
[ __ ] around use that code flagrant now
let's get back to the show i think i
don't know i think just strategically
though kanye's delayed it too much i
think he's [ __ ] up now i agree i
think the first delay was brilliant i
think the second was a bit much and now
it's like bruh bring this drop the [ __ ]
some could say the same for drake okay
al drake said he was supposed to drop in
july but how about this how about this
how about this
now kanye
needs to drop the same day as drake yeah
he has to he has to he's locked to the
drake drop date so now drake controls
your destiny
drake could just sit on his [ __ ] and be
like you know what i think i'm put out
in like a month he can make another
album yeah but he does that he'll look
scared
maybe he can find it that's a good point
right now we know kanye's waiting for
drake to drop drake keeps pushing the
[ __ ] back oh yeah
whatever he does
what if what if he doesn't march instead
what if he drops like a capsule or
whatever tory calls them shits he drops
like three songs drake drops and he goes
just kidding next week drops the real
[ __ ] yeah like oh i mean yeah he could
they could all play with each other he's
got kanye by the balls right now kanye's
drop is locked to drake because he's
mated about drake he gave up all his
power and i also think the difference
between the kanye drake pushback and the
drake like pushing it back there was so
much hype around kanye cuz just uh who
was it that tweeted justin laroy
whatever tweeted like yo i i've never
the kanye's back this is amazing this
whole album is a [ __ ] masterpiece
everybody that was at the listening
party was like this [ __ ] is incredible
there was hype around this kanye is back
yeah and then he pushes all right fine
we'll go to the next listening party
kanye is back and then he pushes and
then he pushes and now it's just like
doug i'm done captain leaks and like
people are listening to it and they're
like
but it's i mean
it's an unfinished leak it's not the the
final album so he could always you know
kanye kind of tweaks the album up until
it comes out and even after it comes out
right so yes it's great we can have a
completely different album by the time
this [ __ ] comes out yeah like my thing
is with the hype this is so good for
both of them because i don't care when
it comes out i'm listening yeah yeah
it's a fight they turned it into a fight
because i remember kanye's last album
the church [ __ ] like i gave that
probably a few weeks went by before i
actually listened to that [ __ ] but this
one the moment it comes out i'm
listening like pablo yeah
and pablo he tweaked up until remember
he was saying blame chad
tweaked it after yeah that just dropped
i remember there was like bars that
changed like i had the first version and
i downloaded it and then the second
version i have two versions of pablo
and what is it like it's like the like
podcast like you can just upload a new
link or whatever yeah a new like a
source file yeah
and then it changes it crazy i have two
versions of pablo
because you bought the first one so it
stays that way you download the first
one ah
yeah man it's i don't know it is
interesting why does everything need to
be a fight why is that the only thing
that we are drawing right this is the
highest stakes why are you the most
competitive why is there sports
we got the best show on tour right yeah
yeah yeah yeah no i understand wanting
to be the best i understand these things
i'm saying like i'm asking like about
our humanity why are we all drawn to
this i am the most drawn to it i love
boxing i love mma i love competition i
want to have the greatest show on earth
not well let's just have a good show i
wanted to be the greatest so but like
why is that so primal to us why is that
instinctual why why why is it when
someone's going yo this album's gonna be
great and then another person goes
mine's gonna be better i'm like
let's get ready to rumble like i just
can't wait all of a sudden that means
i'm like a microcosm of human evolution
it's like it's what everyone wants to
[ __ ] do like it's how we got here is
that yo my tribe is better than your
tribe like my weapon's better than your
weapons and so it's like instilled in
our biology and so when you see it play
out and like sort of a more fun like
you know yeah i can only win if you lose
yeah maybe exactly i think maybe we
gravitate towards stakes yeah maybe
that's it so it's like um like the alpha
male gorillas too also we all want to be
that [ __ ] alpha male we all want to
watch who's going to be the alpha but we
want to see [ __ ] on the line like this
is stupid related to this but like the
crate challenge we're not watching him
see him make it yeah like someone's
going to fail yeah right like we watch
the show wipe out or whiplash wherever
that thing is like where somebody is
gonna fail the stakes are high and when
there's competition putting out an album
if it flops then in the album flops but
putting on an album against someone else
and you lose yeah that's different yeah
that is that's hurt
that's pain yeah there's a reason versus
exists there's a loser in verses yep now
some might say you know in certain
situations both parties win etc but we
really know what time it is
hmm that's the great part about art
competitions is that it's like kind of
subjective yeah you could skirt out yeah
you're in a competition be like you
didn't really win the judges whatever
yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel that's one of
the biggest knocks on fitness career
when he went up against kanye and lost
and then lost yeah like his career was
never the same after that
i think he was always fading a bit it
was tiny but he was still that dude
and then i was like oh [ __ ] this
polo wearing backpack [ __ ] just
took you outside over a gangster maybe
it was different in new york but i was
in la at the time and now you didn't
hear kanye's name ring out and i
remember thinking kanye's doing this i
mean 50 is doing this to try to get back
to
relevancy because he was kind of out of
the mix you didn't hear [ __ ] as much
like oh no new york he was still
happening yeah right yeah new york yeah
he was still bad new york honestly i run
new york yeah that was his song right i
run new york
i mean
yeah man but he was going up against
kanye who was putting out like a
different level of music
i mean that first fit the album was
awesome yeah but it was not it wasn't a
kanye album man it just wasn't i think
that 50's story was just so unique and
interesting
we were like what is this guy he's a
super thug but he also like raps really
cool and even like his voice was kind of
odd yeah you know and that the origin
story was [ __ ] immaculate yeah right
like you just loved it wait shot how
many times what happened and they're not
around anymore what the [ __ ] like you
look you're literally if you saw it in a
movie you wouldn't believe it right if
you saw the scene where the guy gets
shot nine times point blank and then
lives you wouldn't believe it yeah you'd
be like this only happens in a movie
yeah
anyways who do you think wins it it's
kanye drake
i was gonna say kanye i was saying kanye
at first now i don't know there's league
versions like you said like it's taking
too long i think the buzz has died down
i think early on the buzz was so crazy
i think everybody was going to listen
yeah i think he would have won i mean i
was taking too long it's exactly like a
mcgregor fight we're like i'm gonna
watch for kanye but but i think drake's
got it
yeah i mean like mcgregor's fighting
dust i'm like dustin's got the
fundamentals he's got his head all right
i think he's gonna win and do you think
drake wins with it's just bangers
it's
like what is it about or is it drake
brings all the ladies in and the numbers
are just too crazy also what is a win i
think drake's just more consistent okay
yeah yeah that's a good question what
does it win is it first numbers is it
how the people feel about it because
there could be a bunch of kids that just
turned on the drake album they're like
oh this is great this is what we want to
hear but we could also listen to kanye
and go like no this is like ultra light
beam this is one of the greatest songs
i've ever heard in my life and this is
just better music yeah
so what do you guys consider the dub
they're going to go about the numbers
search is straight first day streams or
just first week week yeah usually i mean
i guess like public opinion it would be
one like facet and like what the
conversation is streams and then my
personal take on like whose music i like
better i've been a mixture of all of it
the strange thing is tricky because if
one album has more songs
yeah
that's just gonna get more streams but
can't you just also say one wins because
they're more popular not because of the
album it's just like yep someone has
more
more fans yeah and drake has more cachet
than kanye probably in terms of global
listening community
it's close though like it's really close
yeah
i don't know what up people you just
watch a clip from our weekly patreon
episode you can support the flagrancy
you can support this unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant too alright
peace